>> IT'S ALMOST OVER HERE AT THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY KARATE
CHAMPIONSHIPS.
HE IS TAKING HIS LICKS AGAINST
DEFENDING CHAMPION AND HUMAN
FREIGHT TRAIN SAMMY KNOCKS OF
THE WOLF CLAW DOJO.
>> FIGHT!
>> YA!
YA!
>> KEEP IT LEGAL.
>> SORRY.
I GOT DORK ON THE FLOOR.
YEAH!
WOLF CLAW.
>> WOLF CLAW.
>> YEAH.
>> THIS KID IS A VIRGIN.
THAT WILL TEACH YOU TO TAKE
KARATE.
YEAH.
>> YA, YA, YA!
>> CATCH ONLY THE PENNY.
>> OKAY.
>> MR. JOHNSON, THAT WILL BE
IMPOSSIBLE.
I WON'T BE ABLE TO SEE.
>> LISTEN TO THE WIND.
♪♪♪
>> I THINK YOU'RE READY.
>> I'M GOING TO HAVE SEX WITH
THAT GUY'S GIRLFRIEND AFTER
THIS.
YEAH!
>> LOOK AT THIS.
JEFFY LAHART BACK ON HIS FEET.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE IS BRAVE OR
CRAZY.
>> BAD MOVE, DWEEB.
♪♪♪
>> WHAT'S HE DOING?
>> WHAT THE BUTT?
YEAH!
HOW THE HELL IS HE DOING THIS?
>> LISTEN TO THE WIND.
>> OH!
>> OH, MY GOD.
HE PUNCHED JEFFY LA HLAHART OUT
HIS PANTS AND THROUGH FOUR
WALLS.
>> I PUSHED THAT KID THROUGH
FOUR WALLS.
>> HEY, KNOCKS, IS THAT ALL YOU
GOT?
>> YOU GOT A DEATH WISH, DORK?
>> NO.
>> WHAT YOU DON'T KNOW ABOUT A
WARRIOR IS WHEN A WARRIOR GETS
KNOCKED DOWN, HE --
>> YEAH!
>> OH, POINT KNOCKS.
>> I GOT A THING I GOT TO GET
TO.
>> WELL, UNLESS JEFFY LAHART CAN
GET BACK UP FROM SAILING THROUGH
HIS FIFTH WALL AND A CAR DOOR,
THIS LOOKS LIKE ANOTHER VICTORY
FOR WOLF CLAW DOJO.
>> WHAT THE HELL?
>> OH, MY GOD.
HOW LONG HAVE I BEEN OUT HERE?
>> WHAT DID YOU DO TO MY CAR?
YOU'RE GOING TO GET IT YOU
LITTLE FART WIPE.